合コンモテモテカードゲーム！
！8888888888！
めっちゃテンション高いじゃない！ｗｗｗ８８８！
えーと。ただ今の時刻は深夜二時半でございます。
そして明日の起床時刻は！
七時半です！（イェイ～イ）
88888888888888888888888888888
あっはっはっはっは～
ちょっとツボっちゃったｗ
気合で行こう
おっとっとｗｗｗ
きおきおが遊びに来ました！
ありがとうございます！
いや～うれしいですね。来たいって言ってたんで。来てもらいました！
あっはっはっはっは！
どうですか、静岡は。
いや、めっちゃいいっすね。
合コンモテモテカードゲーム
すごいんだぜ！合コンか～合コンが１００倍楽しくなるやつでほら、
このカードゲームで、貴方もモテモテに・・・
なんか、電話番号聞けたり、気に入ったあの子と帰れちゃうんだってｗ
あの子と帰れちゃうんですか！あの子とキスができちゃう！
えっへっへ～アカーン！合コンとか行ったことある？
ないっす。無いの…ないんすよ。ほ～
えっこれがちですよ。がち？がちでぇ～
何が合コンっていうんですかね？
えっ。うわうわうわうわ～～～同じクラスでですよ、同じクラス。
そうゆう、男女2－2での時に
これをもっていって
遊びに言った女２人と
うわっはぁ～
キスも含めて、男二人で遊んでいきたいと思います。すげぇすげぇすげぇ
えっ、かるたみたいなやつやん。なにこれ？めっちゃかるたじゃん！
コンパ用語、合コン用語明らかに男子の人数が多いコンパのことを、工業高校
って、関ヶ原が１０対１０以上のコンパのこと。
財布の中身が４０００円のことを、アラフォーというらしいです。
タクシー代がなくて、家まで走って帰ることを、アースマラソンというらしいｗｗ
残念な女の子が残念な女の子を連れてきてコンパが中止になることを、新型インフルエンザというらしい。ｗｗｗ
はぁっ、ちょっとまってこれはおもしろい。
残念な女の子をお持ち帰りすることを、モンスターハンターというらしい。
読んだやつをかるたで、ぱぁーんってやって、その取り札の裏にゲームが待っているらしいです。
ちょっと一回並べてみましょう。
ねっは、ここに変な奴が
なんだよこの絵まじで
っはっはっは
はーーい！うわ～これだー！
絶対これですね～見てみます。
はい！
すげー、これマジか？
お～～888　　いやこれやばいじゃん！
これ実戦で出たら、
爆 アド～
一枚でアドレスが三個聞けます。
これは今使えません！
はい。うぉー　早い！　え～ちょっと早くない？　いや俺強いんだよ、かるた
うわぁ～
変顔～
ありがとうございました～
うぃ～　早！いやった～！やったやったやった！
こうゆうことですか？では行きましょう。
そうゆうこと、１０分間
１０っ分間も！
うぃ～　早ーい！きたー
うわぁ、これいいな～　いいすね！
フーフーってやばいですよね？
ただどうせ
はいー！早ーい！　こちらでございます。
もうこれやるしかないじゃん。　やるっすか！逆に想像してみ？
隣が女子だったら
このゲームすごーい！
これがきおきおくんに、ほっぺにちゅーしないといけないんだよね？
うわぁー！
知るか！
うわ～！　はっはっは！くそー！
お～～　あっそれだけ？　それだけです。　超余裕じゃん！
ありがとうございあす！
ったあまこれで、ですよね？待ってこれさー！
ちょっと何かかわいい人だったらさー
でででで、その写真をラインで送るから交換して。
うぁーーーーーーー！
くそマジで、　　はーい！
遠いい！
いきます！
うーわー！　　　なんすかなすかかなんすか
待ってってッてって！　すげー動画だね～
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
うわー　これでもう合コンだったらすごいいいだろね。
うわ、これやばい合コンですよ。普通の人じゃいかない合コンですよ。
まともなねー　できなくなりそうですねー
うわ、もうやばい！　マジカマジカ。
あっはあっはあっは！いきます！
あっはっはっはっは！
うわぁー
1・2・3・4・5
ぷわ～～～！
おうぇｈｄんｆぶいにうべｊ　　ぶわっはっははは！
ヴェー・・・